HAVE A GREAT EVENING,
SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER FROM
NEW YORK.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE ARE TRACKING MULTIPLE
DEVELOPING STORIES INCLUDING
THIS ONE YES FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
FOX NEWS HAS EXCLUSIVELY
OBTAINED THIS SECURITY FOOTAGE
SHOWING NANCY PELOSI, SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE IN NAME ONLY, GETTING
HER HAIR DONE AT A SAN FRANCISCO
SALON DESPITE LOCAL OFFICIALS
FORCING ALL SALONS TO REMAIN
CLOSED BECAUSE OF CORONAVIRUS
CONCERNS.
AS PER USUAL, THE RULES DON’T
APPLY TO NANCY PELOSI.
THE OWNER OF THAT SALON IS
INFURIATED.
WE HAVE ALL OF THOSE DETAILS AND
VIDEO COMING UP.
ALSO TO MIND EVIDENCE HAS
EMERGED THAT I COME IN YOURS
TRULY, AND OTHERS WERE ILLEGALLY
MONITORED BY OUR GOVERNMENT.
FULL DETAILS ON A FULL REPORT
FROM JOHN SOLOMON.
ALSO TONIGHT WE WILL DO
SOMETHING THEY MOB IN THE MEDIA
WILL NEVER DO.
A SPECIAL "HANNITY"
INVESTIGATION INTO THE DEMOCRATS
RADICAL SOCIALIST AGENDA.
WE WILL TAKE A DEEP DIVE TONIGHT
INTO THE BERNIE-BIDEN MANIFESTO.
LATER WE WILL ALSO UNRAVEL THE
LATEST BASELESS SMEARS FROM THE
MEDIA MOB.
THE NUMBER ONE DONORS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
TONIGHT IT IS CLEAR DEMOCRATS
ARE TERRIFIED.
THEY ARE DESPERATE.
THEIR CANDIDATE, WE ALL KNOW HE
IS WEAK AND FEEBLE.
NOW THE RADICAL SOCIALIST
PLATFORM IS THE MOST EXTREME OF
ANY MAJOR PARTY IN HISTORY.
THE RIOTS, THEY ONCE WELL
WOULDN’T SAY A NEGATIVE THING AB
TOLD US THEY WERE PEACEFUL,
THEN OF COURSE THEY TRIED TO
IGNORE THEM AND AS A RESULT OF
THEIR LIVES, THEIR FAILURE OF
LEADERSHIP, WELL, IT’S
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
THE CITIES AND STATES THAT HAVE
BEEN CONTROLLED FOR DECADES BY
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS ARE NOW WAR
ZONES.
AMERICANS OF EVERY BACKGROUND
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC, EVERY RACE,
THEY ARE FLEEING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN DROVES
TONIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATIC ENCLAVE OF
PORTLAND, OREGON, JUST
EXPERIENCED YET ANOTHER NIGHT OF
RIOTING AND MAYHEM.
THIS TIME RIOTERS ATTEMPTING TO
BURN DOWN A LARGE OCCUPIED CONDO
BUILDING WHERE PORTLAND’S
SUPPORTIVE MAYOR OF ANARCHY,
THAT’S MAYOR TED WHEELER,
APPARENTLY LIVES.
I WONDER IF FAKE NEWS CNN
CONSIDERS THIS -- OH, YEAH, SEE
THE PICTURE?
LOOK AT THE PICTURE.
A MOSTLY PEACEFUL OR FIRE?
PEACEFUL RIOTING?
EITHER WAY THE POLICE WERE
FORCED TO DECLARE IT RIGHT AND
NOT BEFORE ARSONISTS STARTED TO
FEED THE FLAMES WITH DEBRIS, A
WOODEN PICNIC TABLE, FIREWORKS.
DO YOU KEEP IN MIND THAT DOZENS
OF INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN LIVE IN THAT BUILDING.
GUESS WHY.
FAR LEFT DEMONSTRATORS, PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS, BETTER KNOWN AS
ANARCHISTS, THEY TRIED TO BURN
IT TO THE GROUND.
MANY OTHER BUILDINGS IN THE AREA
WERE ALSO VANDALIZED.
WINDOW SHATTERED, BUSINESSES
LOOTED.
BEEN WATCHING THIS FOR OVER 100
NIGHTS.
IT WAS ANOTHER NIGHT, TYPICAL
DAY, TYPICAL EVENING IN
PORTLAND, OREGON.
THE CITY WHOSE DOPEY FAR LEFT
MAYOR AND FAR LEFT GOVERNOR
STILL REFUSE ANY AND ALL
ATTEMPTED HELP FROM THE
PRESIDENT WHO’S BASICALLY
BEGGING THEM TO HELP RESTORE
LAW AND ORDER.
THE PRESIDENT KEEP SAYING DAILY
HE STANDS READY TO HELP ANY
AMERICAN CITY OR STATE IN EVERY
WAY POSSIBLE.
BUT HE’S USUALLY, UNLESS HE
INVOKES THE INSURRECTION ACT,
GUESS WHAT, THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
ASK HIM.
TYPICALLY THIS IS HOW IT WORKS.
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS, THEY ASK
FOR THE FEDERAL.
GUESS WHAT.
PRESIDENT HAS PROMISED TO OFFER
IT, GIVE IT ALL.
THAT MEANS MOBILIZING
NATIONAL GUARD.
IN TIMES OF LAWLESSNESS.
WE KNOW HOW TO BEAT BACK
PROTESTERS.
THERE ARE TOOLS POLICE DISPOSAL.
NONLETHAL TEAR GAS, PEPPER
SPRAY, DOZENS OF DEMOCRATIC
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS BARELY
WOULD RATHER WATCH THEIR CITIES
BURN THEN DARE COORDINATE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT IS SAD.
IT IS PETTY.
FRANKLY REPULSIVE AND
DISGUSTING.
IT LEADS TO REAL CONSEQUENCES
INCLUDING DEATH AND DESTRUCTION.
IN CITIES WHERE FEDERAL HELP HAS
BEEN REQUESTED, THE VIOLENCE HAS
BEEN SQUASHED.
IT HAS BEEN DONE OVER.
IN KENOSHA, WISCONSIN, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE LATEST EXAMPLE.
WELL, ORDER HAS BEEN RESTORED
WITH THE HELP OF DONALD TRUMP
AND THE NATIONAL GUARD.
EVEN KENOSHA’S DEMOCRATIC MAYOR
ADMITTED YET, THE NATIONAL GUARD
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
BY THE WAY, PORTLAND, NEW YORK,
SEATTLE, CHICAGO, LOS ANGELES,
SAN FRANCISCO.
LEARN FROM THE MAYOR OF KENOSHA.
>> I WILL TELL YOU, THOUGH, THAT
THE NATIONAL GUARD HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
WE FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT WE CAN
KEEP THE PRESIDENT SAFE AND KEEP
THE PUBLIC SAFE.
MOSTLY WE NEED TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THERE IS CALM IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE HOPING TO MEETING.
>> Sean: HAVE TO REQUEST THE
PRESIDENT WAS ABLE TO RESTORE
LAW AND ORDER AND SAFETY AND
SECURITY IN MINNESOTA.
AND OF COURSE OUR NATION’S
CAPITAL, WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT’S RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT DID HIS JOB TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AND SECURE.
SADLY IN KENOSHA, BEFORE THE
GUARD WAS CALLED IN, AND ORDER
WAS RESTORED, DOZENS OF
BUSINESSES OR ABSOLUTELY WRECKED
WITH MANY COMPLETELY BURNED TO
THE GROUND.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT, HE TORE THE
DEVASTATION AND ANNOUNCED HIS
ADMINISTRATION WAS
ALLOCATING A MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT, 4 MILLION
IN AID TO THE BUSINESSES THAT
WERE DESTROYED.
42 MILLION TO THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN TO BOLSTER PUBLIC
SAFETY EFFORTS.
TODAY ONE STORE OWNER HAD THIS
TO SAY ABOUT THE PRESIDENT’S
VISIT THAT THE MOB AND THE MEDIA
AND OF COURSE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING CAN’T HAPPEN.
IT CAN’T HAPPEN.
IT HAPPENED AND IT WENT ALONG
FINE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EVERYBODY HERE DOES, WE ARE
SO THANKFUL THAT WE GOT THE
FEDERAL TROOPS INTO HELP.
ONCE THEY GOT HERE, THINGS
CALMED DOWN QUITE A BIT.
OUR CITY POLICE AND SHERIFF AND
FIRE DEPARTMENTS ARE AWESOME.
THEY WORKED HARDER THAN YOU CAN
BELIEVE.
>> Sean: LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
LOOK AT THE CROWDS OF SUPPORTERS
ALL IN WISCONSIN.
THEY LINED THE STREETS.
STREET AFTER STREET, MILE AFTER
MILE.
TO SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
MOTORCADE DROVE BY.
OF COURSE JOE BIDEN, HE NEVER
BOTHERED TO VISIT KENOSHA.
HE HASN’T LEFT THE EAST COAST IN
A LONG TIME.
IN FACT, IT’S BEEN, IF YOU’RE IN
WISCONSIN, PAY ATTENTION.
672 DECENCY LAST VISITED THE
GREAT STATE OF WISCONSIN.
TODAY BY THE WAY HE TOOK
JOE BIDEN, A LONG BREAK FROM
CAMPAIGNING.
HE NEEDED REST AND RELAXATION.
REMEMBER THAT FROM THE CARTOON?
BRIEFLY STEPPING OUT OF HIS
BASEMENT BUNKER YESTERDAY
DELIVERING AN EXTREMELY LONG 24
MINUTE SPEECH FROM AN EMPTY ROOM
READING A TELEPROMPTER.
OF COURSE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
QUESTIONS FROM HIS FAWNING
PRESS, THE MEDIA MOB, BETTER
KNOWN A STATE RUN MEDIA.
OF COURSE BIDEN IS NOW SUDDENLY
CONDEMNING THE VIOLENT RIOTS.
A LITTLE LATE, JOE.
A FEW WEEKS AGO JOE SAID HE
ABSOLUTELY WANTS TO REDIRECT
FUNDS AWAY FROM POLICE.
FOR MONTHS, HE DIDN’T HAVE A
SINGLE NICE THING TO SAY ABOUT
ANY OF THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
DAILY.
THAT’S POLICE.
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT PROTECT
AND SERVE.
VERY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
99% OF GOOD COPS.
BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN STAFFERS
ACTUALLY DONATED TO A FUND THAT
HELPED GET RIOTERS OUT OF JAIL.
HE PROMISES THEY WILL HAVE A NO
BOND POLICY, NO BAIL POLICY,
JUST LIKE NEW YORK.
KAMALA HARRIS ACTUALLY PROMOTED
THIS IDIOTIC FUND.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN IT
BACKTRACKING 63 DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
JOE AND KAMALA ARE ATTEMPTING AN
ELECTION TIME CONVERSION.
NOT BECAUSE THEY REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE VIOLENCE AND
DESTRUCTION.
INSTEAD FOR THEM IT’S ALL ABOUT
THE POLLS.
LOOK AT THIS, ACCORDING TO PEW,
THE ONGOING RIOTS ARE NOW A TOP
2020 CONCERN FOR ALL AMERICANS.
IT SHOULD BE.
MEANWHILE, BRAND-NEW EMERSON
POLL SHOWS THAT TRUMP AND BIDEN
ARE IN A STATISTICAL DEAD HEAT.
THE PRESIDENT CLOSING THE GAP
AMONG SUBURBAN VOTERS AND
MINORITIES.
LOOK AT THIS.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW POLLING 24%
WITH AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS.
THAT IS THREE TIMES THE SUPPORT
HE GARNERED IN 2016.
IF THAT NUMBER HOLDS, THIS
ELECTION OR REELECTION IS OVER.
AND OF COURSE THE MEDIA MOB,
THEY ARE WORKING OVERTIME TO
HELP RESCUE JOE AT HIS
STRUGGLING CAMPAIGN.
THE LAST 24 HOURS, THEY
ABSOLUTELY TRASH PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR DARING TO VISIT THE
DESTRUCTION IN KENOSHA.
THE PRESIDENT RESTORED ORDER.
HE DID IT IN MINNESOTA.
HE CAN DO IT IN NEW YORK,
CHICAGO, PORTLAND AND SEATTLE IF
THEY WOULD JUST LIKE HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TOMORROW, FROM OFFICIALS
THERE WHO THINK HIS PRESENCE
WILL ONLY INFLAME MATTERS.
>> AS PROTESTS IN KENOSHA INTO
THEIR SECOND WEEK, THE CITY
BRACES FOR A CONTROVERSIAL
PRESIDENTIAL VISIT.
>> IN KENOSHA, OFFICIALS BRACING
FOR THE PRESIDENT’S PLAN TO
VISIT TOMORROW.
>> THIS IS A CITY THAT HAS NOW
SEEN DAYS OF PEACE, QUIET.
PEOPLE GETTING ALONG.
THERE’S A LOT OF UNITY RIGHT NOW
IN THIS CITY.
THE BIGGEST CONCERN FROM THEM IS
THAT TO HAVE THE PRESIDENT COME
HERE, IT’S JUST GOING TO TRY
THAT ALL AROUND.
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE TOMORROW, I
THINK THEY ARE BRACING FOR
WHAT’S TO COME.
>> Sean: THERE AT FAKE NEWS
CNN THE PANIC IS REALLY SETTING
AND WITHOUT A SHRED OF EVIDENCE.
THEY HAVE ONE OF THEIR DUMB
SO-CALLED POLITICAL ANALYSTS,
CLINTON OBAMA SYCOPHANT,
PROBABLY THE DUMBEST PRESS
SECRETARY IN HISTORY, JOE
LOCKHART FLOATING OLD NEW
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SUFFERED A SERIES OF MINI
STROKES AND HE’S HIDING FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IN BROAD DAYLIGHT OUT EVERY DAY
ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
MORE LIES, MORE FAKE NEWS, MORE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES FROM CNN.
THE PRESIDENT’S DOCTORS, THEY
SAID 1000% FALSE.
SO WHERE’S THE APOLOGY FOR YET
MORE LIES AND MORE HOAXES AND
MORE CONSPIRACIES FROM CNN?
THEY ARE JUST REPULSIVE.
LOCKHART, THE LEFT, THEY ARE
STRICKEN.
THEY ARE THROWING ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING AT THE WALL IN THE
HOPES THAT SOMETHING STICKS.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY ALLOWED THIS
LYING LOCKHART TO SAY ABOUT
NICHOLAS SANDMANN.
BY THE WAY, I HOPE LYNN WOULD
SUE CNN AGAIN.
HE’S ALREADY GOTTEN A LOT OF
MONEY.
BY THE WAY DR. LOCKHART, YOUR
CANDIDATE, THE FRAIL, THE WEEK
JOE BIDEN, IF YOU’RE SO
INTELLIGENT, IF THIS -- DOES
THIS GUY SEEM VERY MENTALLY
ALERT TO YOU?
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
VIDEOTAPE.
>> TOMORROW A SUPERSTAR --
TUESDAY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL.
I TELL YOU WHAT, I AM RUSHING
AHEAD, AREN’T I.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT.
MEN AND WOMEN CREATED BY -- YOU
KNOW THE THING.
DO YOU AGREE WITH ME?
GO TO JOE 30330.
WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS.
PLAY THE RADIO.
MAKE SURE THE TELEVISION --
EXCUSE ME.
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE RECORD
PLAYER ON AT NIGHT, THE PHONE.
MAKE SURE THE KIDS HERE.
>> Sean: HEY DR. LOCKHART,
WHAT’S YOUR DIAGNOSIS?
MAKE NO MISTAKE THE MOB, THE
MEDIA THE DEMOCRATS THEY ARE IN
FULL PANIC MODE.
SADLY THE NEXT 63 DAYS I PROMISE
YOU IT WILL ONLY GET WORSE.
JUST LISTEN TO WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THE MOB EARLIER TODAY.
>> THE PRESS SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF THEMSELVES AND I THINK THE
PRESS IS ACTUALLY, THE MEDIAS
WAS FUELING THIS.
MORE SO THAN EVEN BIDEN.
BIDEN DOESN’T KNOW HE’S ALIVE.
THE PRESS IS REALLY FUELING THIS
AND THEY ARE FUELING IT
HORRIBLY.
YOU’RE DOING A GREAT DISSERVICE
TO YOUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THEY LIE IN UNISON,
THE SAME WORDS, THE SAME
PHRASES, THE SAME TALKING
POINTS.
THE MOB, THE MEDIA, THEY ARE THE
BIGGEST DONORS TO ALL THINGS
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
AND BIDEN’S ANSWER LET’S SPEND
50 QUESTIONS SINCE MARCH.
THEY ARE LETTING HIM GET AWAY
WITH IT.
LET NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED.
THE MOB, THE MEDIA, GUESS WHAT,
THEY ARE NOT IN CONTROL OF THE
FUTURE.
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN 63